gitlab ultimate for ibm cloud packs
the general availability of security
insights and introducing
ibm websphere hybrid edition all on this
episode of ibm cloud now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements
from ibm cloud to get things rolling
this week i want to take a look at the
expansion of ibm's partnership with
gitlab
a move to help companies automate work
across business users
developers and it teams through this
partnership we're excited to announce
get lab ultimate for ibm cloud packs
this is a new way to help you achieve an
open and hybrid devops automation
solution
to embrace and manage diverse tool
chains
with this new solution you can
streamline collaboration to improve
productivity
and accelerate innovation the way that
we're doing this is by integrating git
lab
with ibm cloud packs and bringing ibm
watson ai ops
and devops together to make teams more
agile and efficient
to learn more about gitlab ultimate for
ibm cloud packs and how
all the pieces are working together
check out the link i've got in the
description of this video
next up i'm going to tell you about the
general availability of security
insights
in the security and compliance center
formerly known as security advisor
security insights helps you gain a
better understanding of the potential
risks that can impact your environments
for example you can identify image
vulnerabilities expiring certificates
and threats through network or access
behavior
you also get access to centralized
security risk and posture management
threat detection and security risk
prevention customized alert
notifications suggested remediation
steps
and analysis of your network and
activity data
to learn more about how to enable
security insights hit the link below
to finish things up today i want to
feature one more new offering
ibm websphere hybrid edition it combines
all the products in our websphere
portfolio
with application modernization tools the
goal is to help your business in its
digital transformation initiatives
from optimization and modernization to
cloud enablement
it includes six ibm solutions and the
combination gives you the ability to
transform your existing websphere
applications
to reduce costs and increase efficiency
across your businesses
to find out more about how to address
modern challenges by enabling a phased
approach to digital transformation
see the link below thanks so much for
joining me today for this episode of ibm
cloud now
if you're interested in learning more
about the topics i've covered make sure
you explore the links in the description
of this video
and again please don't forget to
subscribe to our channel to stay up to
date on what's going on in the cloud
now
you